[Applause]
friends
[Applause]
friends nano
[Applause]
right
[Applause]
okay I appreciate that thank you
friends
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I got really grateful for that but
I was gonna say but in a lot of your
reaction I'm not sure it's quite as apt
but I want to say beyond this room -
Australian - supported labour I know
that you're all hurting and I am too and
without wanting to hold out any false
hope while there are still millions of
votes to count and important seats yet
to be finalised it is obvious the Labour
will not be able to form the next
government and so in the national
interest a short while ago I called
Scott Morrison to congratulate him and I
wish Jenny wish Jenny and their
daughters all the very best and above
all I wish Scott Morrison good fortune
and good courage in the service of our
great nation the national interest
required no less
this has been a tough campaign toxic at
times but now that the contest is over
all of us have a responsibility to
respect the result respect the wishes of
the Australian people and to bring our
nation together however that task we won
for the next leader of the Labour Party
because whilst I intend to continue to
serve as the member for Meryem and I
will not be a candidate in the next
favourite leadership ballad along with
my family my precious family the Labour
Party and the trade union movement it's
my life to be able to have served as
leader of the Labour Party for
five-and-a-half years
he's a greater honor than anyone heard
my family before me or even I could have
dreamed of when I joined the local
branch 35 years ago
what I have always loved about the
Labour Party and I still do is the ideas
that we champion it's the people we
empower the people account upon us the
people who need good strong reforming
labour government's gee I wish we could
have formed a government for these
Australians on this evening
I wish we've got a one for the true
believers for our brothers and sisters
in the mighty trade union movement I
wish I wish we could have done it before
[Applause]
one of us not to be Labour's next
victory will belong to our next leader
and I'm confident that victory will come
at the next election
friends the test the test even beyond
victory which I set myself when the
lead-up to this election was that at 6
p.m. when the polls closed when the
final votes were cast I wanted to be
able to look at myself in the mirror and
say there was nothing more that I could
have done no more ideas that we should
have expressed I want to label
all of you can say this we worked
incredibly hard we advanced ideas we
campaigned on a positive vision we were
up front and clear about the reforms
that both sides of politics have ignored
for decades and we've said loud and
clear that Australia needs and needed to
take real action on climate change
clearly some climate action amongst
covers parts of our nation remain deeply
divided for the sake of the next
generation Australia must find our way
forward on climate change and clearly
the coalition's arrangements with one
nation and Clive Palmer have heard our
vote in a lot of places where it
mattered most particularly in Queensland
and New South Wales friends I am
disappointed by tonight's results but I
am not disappointed for me I'll always
be proud of the courage and the
integrity and the vision that our team
showed I'm disappointed for people who
depend upon labour but I'm proud that we
argued what was right not what was easy
this is what politics should be in our
country politics should be the battle of
ideas and I say to all of you here and
all of those tens of thousands of people
the volunteers the candidates that you
leave here tonight with your head held
up I say carry on the fight carry on the
fight for a fair go at work for the
equal treatment of women in their march
to a proper treatment
carry on the park without National
Disability Insurance Scheme and getting
it back on track for a stronger Medicare
and a better deal for pensioners but
above all tonight I say to all of our
supporters those who push the
progressive case for Australia
I say labour is a great party we are a
resilient and proud movement and we
never give up falling down is not our
challenge standing up again is our mark
leave here knowing that we've argued for
the future and our time will come
countable
the only reason I've been able to give
everything to this job for the last
2,000 days is because of the love and
support of Chloe and our kids
I'm not unique everyone and public life
is only here because of the patience and
love of our families but to Chloe
Rupert Gigi and Clementine you've put up
with so much I love you so much I also
want to take the chance to thank all of
my parliamentary colleagues for their
unity for their talent and support in
particular I thank my outstanding deputy
leader Tanya Bluebird sectors and Penny
Vaughn
I offer my commiserations to all those
good labour candidates who fought well
but fallen short as well as friends
who've lost their seats there are too
many people for me to thank individually
tonight they know who they are I want to
say how deeply grateful I am for the
guidance and wisdom of my trusted
advisors for the dedication and hard
work of my staff for the brilliant
passion and enthusiasm of a whole Labour
family from premiers and former leaders
and legends through of course to our
mighty rank-and-file friends over the
past few weeks
it's remarkable millions of Australians
have cast their vote and peacefully
exercised their disagreements and their
right to choose their representatives
people whose ancestors have called this
continent home for 60,000 years and
10,000 resettled refugees many of whom
voted in this election for the first
time in their life
to offer yourself was a leader of such a
great country to seek to serve such
generous and courageous people it is an
extraordinary honor I leave the stage
tonight but I encourage all Australians
particularly young Australians never
lose faith in the power of individuals
to make a difference never give up never
give up aiming for better better be a
country better be a future because the
things that matter most are the things
that are worth fighting for we can't
change the past but my word we can
change the future thank you and good
night
[Applause]